good morning good morning i'm joanne
myers director of narrow house programs
thank you and on behalf of the carnegie
council i'd like to welcome our members
guests and c-span to our books for
breakfast program this morning with
author robert kaplan
will be discussing his book becoming an
hour keith with the end of the Cold War
there was an anticipation that we would
be witness to an era of peace and a new
world order however in a world torn by
exploding populations diminishing
natural resources struggling governments
and ethnic rivalries the frosty clarity
of the Cold War soon gave way to a fog
of peace the common lament which
followed and has so often been heard
from the foreign policy establishment is
how difficult it is to formulate a
coherent foreign policy with which to
address these myriad of challenges
therefore when the keynote essay in the
coming Anarchy was first published in
the Atlantic Monthly in 1994 it was held
not only as one of the most important
and influential articulations of the
future of our planet but as the defining
thesis for understanding the post-cold
war world
since then robert Kaplan's anti utopians
vision of the fault lines of the 21st
century has taken on the status of a
paradigm whether writing about specific
places such as the nations of west
africa or about general trends such as
democratization in the developing world
mr. Caplin unhesitatingly tackles some
of the most difficult issues we'll be
grappling with in this the 21st century
the initial essays in the coming anarchy
identified the terrors of the post Cold
War era while the latter ones seek a
historical and philosophical framework
with which to approach dealing with them
although mr. Caplin takes a grim view of
things to come he expresses his point of
view with persuasion and eclectic
erudition as a journalist mr. Kaplan
covered Eastern Europe when it was
unfashionable to do so in the 1980s when
the media elite was preoccupied with
Nicaragua El Salvador and Lebanon he
covered the Soviet occupation of
Afghanistan he also covered the Horn of
Africa long enough to know about and to
write that the great Ethiopian famine of
1984 and 85 was less a matter of drought
than of Stalinist terror tactics
employed by Ethiopia's Marxist
government today robert kaplan is a
contributing editor for The Atlantic
Monthly in the author of six previously
published books on travel and foreign
affairs that have been translated into
dozens of languages his bestseller
balton ghost was chosen by the New York
Times as one of the best books of 1993
and by amazon.com is one of the top 10
travel books of all times
an empire wilderness and the ends of the
earth were also national bestsellers
with the former being chosen by the
Washington Post and the Los Angeles
Times as one of the best books of the
year and the ends of the earth is one of
the best books listened to at the
Carnegie Council in 1996 for that year
mr. Caplin frequently lectures to the US
military he was a consultant to the US
Army Special Forces and is a fellow at
the New America Foundation won't you
please join me in giving a very warm
welcome to one of our returning
thank you so much I'm a bit intimidated
here when I saw the list of the names
this is a very distinguished audience
this book is a collection of essays
almost all of which in fact eight of
nine of which have been previously
published in the Atlantic Monthly the
national interest and on the op-ed page
of The Wall Street Journal what I'm
gonna talk about today though is I'm not
gonna talk about these essays people can
read them I'm gonna go beyond them and
talk for about 30 minutes about what I
think are the real issues facing us in
the next 10 years to try to put some
coherency to the problems we face
afterwards during questions and answers
though I'll take any questions you have
about the essays themselves or about
anything else you may want to ask about
all right if I was standing before you
say a hundred years ago trying to figure
out what the next century was gonna be
like I would have a lot of grounds for
optimism because three words did not
exist in any dictionary at the time
totalitarianism fascism and inflation
there were all words that were coined
more or less in the third and fourth
decades of the 20th century in other
words the evils the problems of the new
century may not even have names yet so
one has to be very cautious when looking
ahead and of course the 20th century may
be a bad guide to the 21st but it's the
only one we've got so we're forced to
use it the history doesn't repeat itself
but the better we know history the less
surprised we're likely to be by what
happens next all right so if I had to
sum up the problems of the the problem
of the 20th century and say one
television soundbite to use to talk
about the next 20 or 30 years here would
be my my triadic
I would say that what the 20th century
was about was about how populist
movements that came about through a
democratizing tendency were turned into
monsters by utopian ideals and
technology after all both the Nazis and
the Communists were utopians after a
fashion they wanted to remake society
they weren't satisfied with society as
it was and without the tools of the
Industrial Revolution wireless
communications railroads tanks aircraft
carriers factories railway grids they
they couldn't have become what they were
they couldn't have committed the crimes
that they did so if I'm looking ahead at
the next 20 or 30 years using the only
guide I've got behind me which is the
20th century here is what I would say I
would say that what we have to watch out
for is populist movements now spreading
throughout the world because of an
undeniable worldwide trend in
democratization that some of which or
enough of which here and there may be
turned into monsters by utopian ideals
or sectarian or religious ideals and and
and with their power being magnified by
post-industrial technology rather than
by industrial technology um remember the
Bolsheviks came rose up during a
democratizing time in Russia after the
1905 revolution the Nazi Party started
as a legitimate workers rights movement
in 1919 founded by one Anton Drexler
which was only taken over by Hitler a
year or two after that and this was
during a time of democratizing upheaval
the the monarchy had been overthrown and
now we're seeing these kinds of
tendencies throughout the world all
right so first I'm gonna talk about the
problems of democracy and then about the
problems of technology and more more to
the point to distinguish between the
attributes of the Industrial Age and the
post
Industrial Age and then try to put them
together and and see where we are
okay the problem with democracy is that
it tends to emerge best when it tends to
do best when it emerges last as a
capstone to previous economic and social
development in any given society after
you've already got usable institutions
man by literate bureaucrats with
reasonable literacy rates after you've
got some sense of a middle class that
pays some of its taxes after you the big
questions of a society like which ethnic
group if any controls what territory and
where the borders are then democracy
unleashes the economy does a lot of
wonderful things and we've seen that
we've seen it in the southern cone of
latin america in oracle i and recently
in chile and argentina we've seen it in
taiwan and i'm sure enough in a number
of other countries that people people
here can name but the fact is in many
parts of the world elections are being
held in places where the unemployment
rates and inflation rates and weaknesses
of institutions etc are every bit as
worrisome as the unemployment and
inflation rates etc in which hitler came
to power democratically in germany in
the 30s in which muscle Eenie rose to
power democratically in the 20s in italy
during a time of labor strife in italy
the statistics the state of the
institutions in many places in the
developing world one could argue are no
better than in germany in italy in the
20s and 30s
um democracy doesn't make the world but
it doesn't make a society better
automatically all it does is test the
society it exposes its strengths to the
fullest but also exposes its weaknesses
to the fullest and if you have democracy
suddenly in a place with strong ethnic
disputes with a lot of poverty with weak
institutions you're liable to get a
parliament filled with Al Sharpton's
rather than with Edmund
Berks and in fact this is what has
happened in recent weeks in recent
months one could say in Nigeria there
was a very interesting Economist
editorial this week saying that that the
people in northern Nigeria has been is
had a string of ethnic rioting since
since the democracy was re-established
some months ago by some estimates there
have been about two 2,500 people killed
about 500 of whom just in the last two
weeks alone it's Braddock it's chronic
and recently it's been it been ignited
by that by the drive of the northern
provinces to establish Islamic law which
has made a lot of the Christians in the
southeast and elsewhere angry with the
Economist editorial pointed out is the
people demanding Islamic law in the
north are not the mullahs who are very
conservative as it happens in Nigeria
it's the new democratically elected
politicians in the north who like
democratically elected politicians in a
lot of poor countries need money need
contributions appeal to the galleries to
the grandstands it was democratic
politicians which drove Turkish policy
to be more extreme in 1974 it was the
millet though the military did the
invasion of Cyprus the military was
actually the conservative force behind
the scenes in Turkish politics at the
time Yugoslavia it's a fact that all the
violence in Bosnia happened after not
before democratic elections in in
various regions of the ex-yugoslavia
that the story of the ex yugoslavia is
to one degree the story of the end of an
authoritarian rule and the beginning of
democratizing tendencies and what that
exposes is another problem of democracy
is when we read about democracy in a
place we think oh it's unleashing human
rights universal rights the rights
against torture the rights for an
independent judiciary and that's all
true can be true but it's also true that
it also unleashes group rights the
rights to be suddenly Nigerian Muslim
the
to be a Nigerian Christian the rights to
be of bosnian-serb it unleashes group
tendencies as well and in places where
the group tendency or mentality is
strong and institutions are weak and the
Western enlightenment or the equivalent
of that and another culture is also weak
democracy can make things worse just as
it can make things better
it Algeria and Tunisia is yet another
example Tunisia has only held fixed
elections where the President Zine El
Abidine Ben Ali always makes sure he
gets 98% of the vote um kind of Tunisia
has been at peace it's a far more stable
happy society than night than Algeria
which expect which experimented with
democratic elections in the early 90s as
Tunisians never tire of telling me is
we've got 25-30 percent unemployment if
you had really free elections in our
country the equivalent of the iguana
Muslim meme the Muslim Brotherhood would
wouldn't if not a majority that they
would gain a sizable minority
destabilize politics and you would have
a lot of problems and the and the
quality of life of the individual person
might go down rather than up um
Venezuela in Chile I know it's very
fashionable to condemn Pinochet and all
of that I'm gonna put my foot in my
mouth I'm right now Pinochet was a
terrible man I think 3,000 people in new
york times wrote with tortured and
disappeared under his rule 3000 reasons
to hate him
I mean I have no problem with this it's
also a fact that Venezuela has been
democratic since 1959 and has almost
nothing to show for it um the elite has
its money in Miami bank accounts it's it
Caracas is the city of gated communities
of fortress communities of gangs it's
and Chile now may be the only developed
economy outside of the Pacific Rim in
the 1990s that has seen steady eight
nine percent yearly growth rates this is
not an argument for Pinochet it's just
an argument for the complexities and
ironies
of democracy and then of course there's
China in Russia I there are a lot of
differences between China and Russia
cultural historical geographical but one
difference is that Russia went cold
turkey into democracy had Gorbachev's
capitalists trending authoritarianism
been allowed to stay on for another
seven or eight years it's quite likely
that the average Russian would live
better today and Russia would be more
stable
Edmund Burke always favored two slow
transitions not fast dramatic
transitions cos it tended to be easier
on the individual person China is a
one-party autocracy yet I'm not sure
there is another example in recorded
economic history of so many people in so
short of time seeing their economic
well-being measurably improved so
dramatically and it's not just economic
well-being it's personal freedoms we
have to make a distinction between
personal freedoms and political freedoms
yes they don't have the right to vote
but in the last twenty years or about
Chinese can open a foreign bank they can
open a bank account they can travel
internally gay and unmarried couples can
live together a lot of restrictions have
been lifted off so that people have
become individuals in China rather than
a mass and in a country where less than
10 percent of the country is middle
class where you have grave ethnic
disputes not like the Soviet not like
the X Soviet Union but still extremely
severe not just between Chinese and
Tibetans but particularly between
Chinese and ethnic Uighur Turks in the
West cold-turkey democracy overnight
would probably weaken and destabilize
China and could lead to an even worse
human rights situation all right the
real issue instability is not whether or
not a country holds elections or not
it's how healthy and sizeable is the
middle class you show me a place with a
sizable healthy enlarging middle class
I'll accept an argument for optimism you
show me a place without one it
doesn't matter how many elections have
been held there the place is
unpredictable Thailand is a good example
sizeable healthy middle class had a
terrible crisis a few years ago but
because it already has a sizable healthy
middle class with Thailand needs is more
democracy not less because it's ready
for it ok so the problem though is that
if you look at history in most cases
most of the times middle classes are not
created from scratch by democracies they
tend to be created from scratch or
started by some form of authoritarianism
or other and then once the middle class
gets large enough it tends to be very
ungrateful and throw out the very
autocrats that created it in the first
place so if citizens of Singapore get
tired of the present rule would only
prove that point though I don't want to
use Singapore as an example because it's
a city-state it's not a real country and
it's much easy to easier to control a
small relatively mono-ethnic or urban
area than it is a large expansive region
like China all right so if the middle
class is the key to stability and if you
look at population trends around the
world
all right demographers will tell you
that the rate of population growth is
coming down but that to me is not
interesting what's interesting to me is
that the absolute numbers of people
being put on the earth in the in the 30
or 40 poorest countries are still
increasing at a very rapid rate and and
and these countries are becoming
increasingly urbanized and most
importantly about 90 percent of the
births worldwide are among the world's
poorest people or or in the in the
world's poorest countries or in the
poorest sections of wealthier countries
which means while the middle class is
certainly increasing in absolute terms
which is providing a lot of new markets
for American goods etc in relative terms
it's not really increasing so we face
the same problem of instand if the
middle class is the key to stability you
can see with the
and another problem is urbanization
because urbanized societies are harder
to rule than rural societies they're
more complex they require complex
infrastructure sewage potable water and
electricity all sorts of they're subject
they're very sensitive to food price
fluctuations because people in rural
communities can grow their own food they
can deal with shortages but suddenly
urban populations are very sensitive to
prices to shortages so in the developing
world we see that the margin for error
is getting wider and the margin for
success is getting narrower because so
many rulers of developing countries are
ruling countries that every day every
year are increasingly urbanized and yet
the percentage of the middle class in
many of these countries is not going up
all right so if democracy is not the
solution and if 1950s style
dictatorships don't work either and have
just as many problems or more than the
ones that I've enumerated about
democracy what are we likely to see I
think what we're likely to see over the
next decade or so is what the ancient
Greeks lucidity 's polybius called mixed
regimes or hybrid regimes this is not a
new idea it's not a new idea at all what
it all it means is a regime anywhere
that combines tendencies of what we
think of as democracy and tendencies of
what we think of as authoritarianism and
if we go around the tables we can all
come up with examples of that um Turkey
is officially a democracy you can't be a
member of NATO without being a democracy
but the National Security Council is
more powerful than the civilian
Parliament and as Turkish journalists
say at the council meetings the civilian
politicians come as tourists to listen
and the generals come with thick
dossiers with which to lecture another
example of course was up until last
October Pakistan which was a military
state with some democratic dressing now
that
ghost has been given up now it's it's an
overt military state but still not like
in the 50s because it seems to me at
least that the new ruler of Pakistan is
more of a kind of weak consensus figure
he's been fairly indecisive he doesn't
have the leeway of maneuver of a classic
1950s style um general Peru of Venezuela
with Chavez recently people who were
elected democratically and saw their
popularity rates go up after they did
away with a lot of constitutional rights
because the average person was fed up
with unlimited democracy and seemed to
launch some sort of a compromise a king
Hussein's regime in Jordan has been was
for decades an excellent example of a
hybrid regime in the sense it was
officially undemocratic in many ways but
the king king always consulted with
various members of the community before
taking a decision and when the
Parliament really got instituted in the
80s and really got sovereign power of
course here and there when it took a
move when it did something that the
royal family didn't like like in 1994-95
when it tried to abrogate the peace
treaty with Israel the royal family
stepped in so Jordan is very much a
workable hybrid regime I think that if
South Africa intends to get its crime
rates down tends to get its unemployment
rates down it will have to continue to
be called a democracy and we will all go
along with the lie but behind the scenes
it may have to become more of a hybrid
security services business oligarch
oriented regime Hong Kong is emerging as
a kind of hybrid regime run by business
oligarchs real estate oligarchs behind
the scenes
Bulgaria is a bad example of a hybrid
regime because it's officially a
democratic success story unofficially
about six or seven crime groups share
sovereignty with the group all right
yeah the bottom line here is that never
go by what a system is called because
every system is gonna call itself a
democracy
and all of our officials are gonna say
yes the success of democracy decide on
what a regime is by how the power
relationships actually work behind the
scenes all right I've talked enough
about democracy in terms of Technology
the Industrial Revolution was that
bigness is about big aircraft carriers
big tanks factories railway grids etc so
the only people who could take advantage
of it who could see their power
magnified by it were people who owned
big geographical space that's why the
Industrial Revolution magnified the
crimes of Stalin and Hitler and Mao and
why I think we're not gonna have that
kind of evil in the 21st century why
we're not gonna have it because the
qualities of the post-industrial
revolution are different they're about
two smallness you're about the diffusion
of matter they're about the diffusion
the spread of power but the problem is
his knowledge becomes spread it also
becomes vulgarized
it gets put into the hands of a lot of
badly educated people if you look
through history again the 20th century
it's not uneducated poor people who
caused the problems nor very
well-educated rich people or well-off
people it was always badly educated men
Mangus too highly mario Pol Pot Hitler
Stalin all more or less fall into this
category they had smatterings of
education they had read a number of
books they had big ideas into small
heads so to speak they didn't come from
the poorest classes they came from the
lower middle classes um a Pol Pot I
think was the son of like a medium-range
Cambodian landowner who got a lot of big
ideas in his head at the Sorbonne
so and and and the the post-industrial
revolution computers the web etc is
putting a lot of information in power
into a lot of individuals who fall into
this category all the wonderful things
that are being said about the computer
the internet were basically could have
been said about Gutenberg's printed word
about the Bible and what did that lead
to well once you had texts and you know
in the Middle Ages late Middle Ages you
had thing
that people could argue about it because
they get they couldn't just argue about
big things suddenly they had little
things that could argue and and D
legitimize each other about so it led to
doctrinal controversies which led to the
counter-reformation which led to the
religious wars so McGann don't
necessarily think that the compute that
the the the web all of this is gonna
bring us together will it'll create a
new global elite certainly um that will
have similar universal values that will
set up new institutions internationally
but will it'll also unleash differences
at the same time so if you put all this
together
urbanization post-industrial technology
democratization and the fact that the
middle class is not enlarging in in a
relative sense I think we're gonna see a
decade or two of constant crises I don't
think we're gonna see a massive villain
on the scale of Hitler or Stalin because
those are the people we're ready for I
mean people argue about a P talk about
appeasement ad nauseam it's gonna be the
things who are not ready for these small
crises and and it's precisely gonna be
our belief in democracy and our wanting
to spread democracy that may unleash
some terrible crimes and tendencies
throughout the world Indonesia had a
democratic election in June and it had
massacres in East Timor in September
I'm not saying one led to the other but
what I am saying is one is related to
the other I'm not saying that democracy
in nigeria led to 2500 people being
killed in ethnic rioting but i am saying
that there related to the to each other
they're part of a similar process take
to conclude the most important thing i
believe and i say this in my last essay
if there's the most important sentence
or so in this in this collection it is
that it is it is precise
at times that are prosperous and
optimistic that we need to maintain a
sense of the tragic because if you
maintain a sense of the tragic the
chances are you Kuna you can avoid it
before World War one policymakers in
London and France and elsewhere had
several decades of more or less economic
prosperity and growth behind them they
had several decades of more or less
peace in Europe the franco-prussian war
lasted only nine months that was fought
mainly between armies not civilians
between the Polian and World War one
there was no major Cataclysm fought on
the in the heart of Europe so people had
to a certain extent lost the sense of
the tragic and they had stumbled into
World War one the founding fathers of
the American Revolution if I'm sure
number of lawyers in the room have read
the Federalist Papers and you know then
that the Federalist Papers written by
Madison J Hamilton or works of profound
pessimism almost every sentence is about
what can go wrong in human relations and
it was precisely because the founding
fathers thought in terms of what could
go wrong
because they didn't trust anybody they
didn't trust the king but they didn't
trust the masses because of Cromwell too
that they were able to create a system
that was built on pessimism that led to
two hundred and thirty years of optimism
and the French Revolution was built on
optimism it was built on the rights of
man and it ran into problems the
guillotine Napoleon's dictatorship etc
so if I could leave you with one thing
it's it's precisely at times like this
to maintain a sense of the tragic thank
you very much and I'll take whatever
questions you have
I'd like to open the floor to questions
and I ask that you identify yourself
keep your questions brief into the point
and please wait until the microphone
reaches you shashi I'm sorry wait the
microphone because I'm sure she thorough
and as you know Robert I enjoy your
writing immensely and today I think I've
enjoyed your speaking even more than any
one of us might have dared hope thank
you for that stimulating performance I
have one comment and one question the
the description of democracy that
occupied much of your talk this morning
it seems to me misses out on two things
which I'd like you to comment on one is
of course the fact that there is
evidence to the contrary when you start
looking at democratic and non-democratic
governments performance particularly in
the economic census both spoke of Chile
for instance you have examples like
Botswana which has had a far better
grade rate of growth then in most
countries louder are you have examples
like Botswana which helium which have
had a far more impressive rate of growth
than many authoritarian countries and
which indeed are preserved democracy
from the earliest movements but the
second problem with your thesis appears
to be that you miss the value of
democracy as a value in itself that is
that if you reduce democracy to an
instrument to a means to better economic
performance you miss out on the various
intangibles that make democracy valuable
for those who practice it those who
benefit from it and those who are not
oppressed by the alternatives to it and
that to me is is a crucial issue that I
would like you to address and that in a
sense leads me to the the question
following the comment of the question is
question where is India fit into your
okay
all right the first question a lot of
the first question basically says that
democra there are economic studies that
show that democratic regimes do better I
would say that a lot of places that are
called Democratic regimes as I said in
my talk are not really democratic
regimes
they're called democratic regimes and
this is a feeling I get as a reporter
some I'm a reporter I'm a journalist I'm
not I'm not an academic I don't do
studies from a university when you go to
many of these places that are called a
democracy and you find out how things
are being run yeah I'm the reason
they're stable is often because of the
role of security forces and other and
and other elites that are precisely non
democratic that don't show up on any
economists chart also there are specific
conditions but SWANA was for years built
up and propped up by a regime that we
all hated South Africa but which also
had some good points to it even during
apartheid such as a judiciary that here
and there could operate fairly
independently even during the times of
apartheid so it was it's precisely its
proximity to a regime that would that we
love to hate that helped Botswana a lot
along the way
the second issue what was the second
question shush yeah all right yes always
it in itself i here's where we have a
basic philosophical difference right i
think that elites sit around and talk
about democracy and human values and the
average person that i have interviewed
and met in slums around the world and
various thinks only about their
self-interest the self-interest of their
family the well-being of their children
their extended family tribe and clan and
what will be better for their
self-interest and an arising economy
which we think of oh that's just
economics it's not about human rights i
think i'm freedom from living in a
malarial bog to a place that has potable
water and sewage is a human right on the
exact same scale as
as freedom of speech and judiciary
Isaiah Berlin wrote in an introduction
to his four essays on Liberty that in
those countries that don't even have
minimum security where there isn't
enough to eat there isn't clean water
are not places where people should be
expected to worry about freedom of the
press the wonderful thing about Berlin
was he's so subtle and he has all these
exceptions to his grand rules but I find
that a lot of people quoting him or miss
are not looking at the exceptions that
he cited and in many of the places where
people are recommending democracy there
in places where you've made an exception
as far as India um I think the real
story about India and I wrote about this
in the end of the earth and that that
doesn't really come out is the
decentralization of India the kind of
that India's has has always had many
realities but even more so now you have
almost first world states like Kerala
with you know with with certain
statistics that evil Canada's and then
you have really third world fourth world
places like Bihar where you have
vigilante justice and all of that I
think the MA
not a piece it peaceful is a relative
term I know there's a lot of violence
Scheduled Caste clashes that never get
in the newspapers here but there's a
relatively gradual and peaceful
devolution that's being hidden by the
fact of this centralization of military
power on the top and the clash with
Pakistan and Kashmir also if India
breaks up it may not matter because
India has geographic coherency Pakistan
does not if Pakistan broke up it could
be a nuclear nuclearized in Yugoslavia
in the making but India could break up
over decades and it would be like a
fourth page news story we wouldn't
notice it till after the fact see to me
democracy is also decentralization what
Thais say is we're not a democracy it
doesn't matter how many elections we've
held because too much power is in
Bangkok until we we decentralized and
give up power we won't be a full
democracy so I think that's one of the
reasons why India has been able to hold
together and despite everything managed
but if you've read the piece by I think
it was punk rush in the New York Review
of Books piece about five weeks ago it
pointed to a lot of the problems and
nasty stuff that actually go on during
Indian elections
the Muslim or Islamic world it's more
than a billion people extends from the
Atlantic to Central Asia what are the
prospects of of development in that area
taking into consideration the economic
social developments as well as the
information revolution that is affecting
our societies tremendously thank you all
right
um I see the whole Islamic world from
Morocco to Iraq and I'm not calling this
a bad case scenario call it a neutral
scenario it depends how it goes as will
become a series of messy Mexico style
devolution
over the next 10 or 20 years pick a
number why why do I compare places like
Egypt to Mexico or Syria to Mexico it's
because Mexico's got a newly dynamic
middle class it's it's a developing
country but it kind of a higher level
it's seen rapid urbanization and social
change over the last few decades like
places like Syria and Lebanon and has a
real problem with drugs and that that
have undermined a lot a lot of the
structures and Mexico held together
under a single party kind of somewhat
authoritarian thug ah cracy for several
decades that promoted development and
change the society and ASRA
but now it's outlived its usefulness and
there's like a messy devolution
occurring that is not necessarily going
to make Mexico more stable or easier to
deal with if you take Egypt if you take
Syria you take Morocco take some other
countries in the region the like we've
there's been a lot of change in the
Middle East we've had their middle the
Arabs are urbanized now
Persians are urbanized they weren't
fifty years ago but one thing that
hasn't changed is you still have one man
rule in a lot of places you still have
emergency law in many places but the
next generation of autocrats in the
Middle East are not going to be able to
rule as autocratically as the present
generation that's the real destabilizing
element that whoever 6sc succeeds
Mubarak and Assad and many others are
not going to have the luxury the masses
are not going to be so subservient
they're gonna demand more because you
have critical size middle classes that
are part of the global economy but yet
at the same time I'm not convinced that
any of these countries are suited for
what we call Western parliamentary
democracy so I think what you're gonna
get is what I said some many messy
Mexico style scenarios where instead of
one ruler you may have some collage of
five or six Colonels and civilian
politicians and that is not necessarily
going to help development it's not
necessarily going to make things more
stable but it might it depends in each
individual country I think the last
plate the last issue to focus on in
terms of the future of the Middle East
is the israeli-palestinian issue to me
that is the most boring issue in the
whole region and the reason is because
all it is is that it's it's a long
drawn-out divorce process there has
already been an independent Palestinian
state on the ground since December 1987
since the Intifada started an individual
Israeli citizens felt unsafe going
hiking in the West Bank over the weekend
traveling to Gaza to buy wicker
furniture over the weekend from that day
on there was a de facto independent
Palestinian state and all this is about
is working out the divorce proceedings
or also so the real questions we need to
focus on this Syria have a future what
what will become of Egypt after Mubarak
these are issues and I don't have
answers but the country that me seems to
be the best kind of model in terms of
the positive and the negative because
there's a lot of positives
going on in Mexico is Mexico mr. de Paul
ding the comment first your concept of
so-called induction of so-called
democracy in Russia 1905 the Duma was
not it's a democratic there was never
any implementation of that in the vine
Mars the situation the Constitution was
was written with one clause called the
enabling act which was also used in the
Third Reich now my IVA comment and that
I take issue with is use of this term
democracy democracy takes on various
various forms predicated in the
sociological the economic etc etc if
you're speaking of democracy in the eyes
in the framework of the United States
this is not and was not originally but
to be a democracy these are only terms I
think you have to focus on the basic
concept of what we're talking about in
this if we're talking about a middle
class in the United States yes there's a
large was middle class England based on
its archaic laws and no Constitution did
not really have a middle class until
after World War one and two and the
other country so therefore we are
looking at this with a difference in
nuances with yoga Slavia was not was
democratic even after with Tito's death
so therefore I think we can look at it
in a different way and possibly convey
an erroneous error when we talk about
the democracy structures along with
Jubilee
judicial system etc okay let me agree
with you and disagree with you at the
same time I'm obviously democracy is a
shorthand for a lot of things civil
society independent judiciary taxation
that's predictable or not onerous a lot
of good things but as it happens we have
come or rather in terms of the public
have come
to define democracy by the way that the
US government and other governments have
defined it in their public statements
and if you look at the public statements
of the Secretary of State for example
over the last eight or nine years a
reasonable person would be led to
believe that democracy is synonymous
with elections that for instance kabila
should hold elections or he can't get
aid so because because such powerful
influential actors of the US government
has short-handed this I'm forced to use
this definition but I agree with you all
right and it is true that specifically
by Maher in the 30s and the duma in 1905
were not democratic but as Alexander
Solzhenitsyn points out in his novel
November 16 1916 he talks about how
after 1905 suddenly people were talking
and arguing about politics and buses and
trolley cars that they never did before
and when you read about vie mara Germany
you find that we're talking about
relative terms we're arguing among gray
areas that that that the 19-teens in
Russia up until the outbreak of world
war one war a time when people were
there was some democratizing tendency
going on a little bit more on your
forecast for the future of Mexico ah yes
um Mexico actually is it's kind of like
the Balkans I mean if you look at the
map it's divided by mountains tremendous
mountain groups it was not really a
united country or a stable country up
until about nine the 1930s the Mexican
Revolution went when it went on for 11
years with no demonstrable result the
independence battle about Spain dragged
up with Spain dragged on for a decade
the entire nineteenth century were a
period of low-level Wars and conflict in
Mexico it's only from about the first
third of the 20th century onward that
Mexico became a really cohesive modern
state
and the result was a success story a
population doubled and tripled
industrial capacity grew dramatically
exports began you know the class
structure went from peasants to being a
very complex class structure and as a
result the ruling party elite the
one-party oligarchy was so successful
that it worked itself out of a job I
mean because it is no longer useful
anymore to the further development of
Mexico because it is too autocratic now
for the complex society that that it
created it helped create in the first
place so I think right now we're at the
point where Mexico is that it is at
another is it another era of upheaval
and this up people may be positive you
know it may be very productive on the
other hand it may not be the one
advantage that Mexico has that other
complex developing countries like Brazil
like India like Nigeria don't have is
it's got a border with the United States
it's got an escape valve um so the US
economy helps it in immeasurable ways
and immigration you know it you know
it's a place to discharge excess labor
and that is a very very big advantage
and that may be why it may be wise not
to be too pessimistic about Mexico I
wonder if I could ask you to go into
problems of populism in the United
States the Republicans want to have a
strong defense by building more ships in
Mississippi and cutting the federal
budget the Democrats want out a strong
defense by raising salaries at the
better housing and they never saw an
entitlement program they didn't want to
increase and this leaves a president
with no money to pay off the Sirians if
you get a Middle East settlement and no
money to rebuild North Korea if they
collapse and we're in an age of
degenerating populism in this country
could you deal with that yeah
America has always had populist
movements we've always had militia
movements even violent militia movements
there was Shay's rebellion in
Massachusetts there was the Whiskey
Rebellion in western Pennsylvania in
fact George Washington didn't really
become the real president of the United
States
till he used physical force against his
own people to put down the whiskey
rebellion that's what a lot of
historians consider the real beginning
of the United States once the federal
government was willing to use force
violence against its own people to show
that it really had muscle the difference
though is that in those days a rebellion
rebellion was the local rebellion now we
have technology which magnifies the
power of a small group of people
magnifies in terms of the media any nut
can get on TV and hold a press
conference any populist rabble rouser
can have 20 cameras around them and then
a few people just five or eight people
who are relatively intelligent and
technologically proficient couldn't get
plastic explosives of fertilizer
explosives and all of this so the
whiskey rebellions and the Shay's
rebellion now have these advantages of
technology that did not exist in the in
the past but at the same time the
federal government is much stronger than
it was in the past
it also was able to use technology and
things that it could not do before
traveling in the you know in 200 years
ago from Boston to to Washington was an
arduous Trek like crossing Afghanistan
today I mean it is no longer so I think
the forces of kind of balanced America
has always been a very messy place I
mean I just came from Canada last night
and Canadians are always talking abut
you know they're always critical and
worried about the US because there's so
much turbulence but I I think this I
don't see the level of turbulence is any
higher now than at any previous stage in
our history really
can you hear me
let me begin by joining Shashi Tharoor
in complimenting year on the quality and
stimulating aspect of what you've said
the first thing however I disagree with
you about is when you said that you're
not an academic you you don't have
university quality tap analysis I
disagree strenuously and not least
perhaps because you've not given us the
solution that's that's what often
happens in that's what often happens in
the university now my comment before my
question is this it seems to me that you
got to the real point of of what you
were saying amongst many fascinating
things yeah when you refer to Berlin
right and that real point it seems to me
is the question of the relationship
between democracy and us as a system of
government and justice and the ability
of it to deliver social goods goods that
people value whether it's potable water
being free of malaria or in today's
world money wealth and so on you now in
some ways you've wanted to try to
disconnect those and I think you're
probably right as our friend over here
in the corner suggested democracy
doesn't have a single definition and the
very idea as some popular American
ideologues today argue of saying that
there is one democratic system and it
will inevitably produce one high quality
of life is of course palpable nonsense
the real point is what is the connection
between any given system of govern
and its ability to deliver socially
relevant goods and I think you're right
in raising that question suggesting that
there's no single connection between
those two that will inevitably work I
was disappointed when you mentioned
mixed systems as one possible solution
that you left out rudy giuliani polish
journalist had said to me that Giuliani
fascinates people in Poland he makes the
trains run on all right yeah it's just
very quick now it's and the reason he
fascinates people in Warsaw is because
everyone in Poland knows they need a
Giuliani but that if they had one it
would descend into dictatorship
overnight that it's precisely the
American system which is so well
established that could handle someone
like that but other countries cannot and
that's why he fascinates them at your
point and you know I was making not
simply a joke about Julia yeah I mean
what I say yeah I go around this place
as you do and I'm constantly exposed to
New Yorkers saying he's he's really done
a great job in making this city safer
and better and so on yeah and you cannot
get a serious discussion going on the
question of yes but at what Democratic
cost right right now I'm also
disappointed that you left out my other
friends that aren't the same because it
seems to me that if one of this one of
the goods that democracy should deliver
is social order then he's got to be one
of the world's leading Democrats because
the place is certainly in good order
in that sense social order but as you
said at the breakfast table delivered
under halogen lights and wire fences
okay enough of me what's the solution
this is my question what what's the
solution in the age of the Internet in
particular where so much relevant
information can be bowdlerized trashed
or even turned into pornography how do
you close this gap of understanding that
there isn't one single democratic system
that will produce the social goods that
you posit or in Isaiah Berlin posited
that all people want without yourself
becoming an austerity rien yeah and
saying through the net or where else
this is the way and the only way that
you must think and act about this okay I
deal with Mac with Sudan who's Hussein
and Giuliani there's a part of the
prince
Machiavelli's The Prince where he's
talking about a fourth century BC civis
Sicilian tyrant and he and he talks
about when it's okay to use physical
force and when it's not and
Machiavelli's definition was this and
I'm giving it to you because I'm
comfortable with I mean in an imperfect
world he said it's okay to use the
minimum amount of force and what we call
anti-democratic mechanisms necessary
provided it's only for the sake of the
greater good of the polis and by greater
good Machiavelli defines that too
because he was a humanist and in his
time he didn't just mean making the
trains run on time so he said when a
leader uses force and violence
specifically to promote the greater good
and then stops using it the minute he's
able to improve the greater good and
then uses only that amount necessary
then it's justified but in the case of
this fourth century BC Sicilian tyrant
he used too much so Machiavelli said
this man was not virtuous he had no
virtue so what Machiavelli is doing is
he's making distinctions he's saying
just because autocracy may be good in
certain situations and democracy not
good in certain situations you will
always have extremes you will always
have autocrats that are so bad that
almost anything is better than than
their rule
and not only is Iraq an example but
Milton of Beaute in Uganda in the early
1980s um about 15 years ago I wrote a
long piece for the Atlantic when you
Cerie you you arey Museveni came to
power and one of the things i said was
when a boat had killed more people than
ideo mean about a million people all
that many of the experts were saying but
anyone else will be worse you know and
then other experts said what's worse you
know once you get to this point throw
out all your theories and just try
anything you know there's something
liberating in an extreme situation
because it allows you to be bold you
know it makes absolutely clear cut what
your values are and your objectives and
I think Iraq is an example of an extreme
situation but what I was dealing with in
my talk was most of the situations in
the world are not so extreme
they're very messy and muddy and back to
Berlin to answer the last question about
the relationship between the different
kinds of social goods like potable water
or yeah human dignity or freedom when
Berlin died his acolytes wrote that the
best thing about him was his pluralism
the fact that he accepted that there
were no answers that there were many
different answers and that each
situation would have its own result
would have it would have its own answer
yeah III don't think there is a solution
to this I think um it's not written that
there is a solution to every difficult
case in history or in current affairs
often you have ten bad choices and you
take the least bad choice and in many
cases you'll you'll do away with certain
liberties to enhance other liberties and
it's not because you want to do away
with some it's simply because you have
no choice on they just Lee Kuan Yew
clearly has accentuated certain
liberties that we value in Singapore
given that in the 1960s it was as poor
as many places to sub-saharan Africa but
at the cost of others in a
perfect world he would accentuate both
but the world we live in all I'm saying
is that in many situations we will have
to make choices
and that's the best non-academic answer
I can yeah okay unfortunately our time
is that I know we could listen to you in
a perfect world for much longer but I
thank you for being with me
mr. Kaplan's book is available for sale